so now we have fun so two speakers and
these two species will also be on the
panel will have two additional so the
first finish are about fairness and vice
thanks for the introduction and for the
invitation to speak so has been to said
I'll talk a little bit about this
intersection of fairness and my upfront
kind of disclosure disclaimer is that
this isn't gonna be super about deep
learning but I think the ideas are
general too and yeah these types of
statistical models and so I'll try to
draw those connections out so I'm gonna
make a somewhat controversial claim and
so I want to put it up front first and
then I'll dive into this a little more
and so my claim is is actually twofold
so the first claim is that that recently
there's been this whole set of
definitions to audit models and to
understand what it means for models to
be fair and I'm gonna argue that
essentially all of these released a big
class of these these group based
definitions of fairness are for poor
proxies for detecting discrimination so
even though we use these two models I'll
argue that they're they're quite poor at
that at that task and the second one is
even who are more consequential that not
only are they port auditing but if we
were to use these as positive measures
to build models as design principles
then in fact they can lead to these
perverse decisions and so these rubrics
that we've been developing over the last
several years they they have these twin
problems that both about it auditing and
they're bad as design principles these
are controversial I know so I'll try to
explain this in much more detail and
please feel free to to push back as I as
I'm talking out you know
okay so first I just want to give an
overview of algorithmic decision-making
in the broad abstract sense and I'll
frame everything in this case study
machine buys probably many of you have
seen this that came out a few years ago
now you know was talking about the
deployment of algorithm to help judges
decide whom to release when their
pending trial so just to make sure we're
all on the same page
what is this context so in the u.s.
after some was arrested usually 24 to 48
hours after someone's arrested a judge
has to make this high-stakes decision
about whether or not that individual
should be released or detained pending
this trial which might happen in weeks
or months in the future and this is
tricky there is this this goal is to
balance the social financial costs of
incarceration so someone might lose
their job they're disconnected from
their family the state has to pay for
incarceration this is a pretty big
social and the flipside there is this
obligation or desire to keep the public
safe and so how does one balance these
costs so historically how is this done
judges would user intuition their
experience and you just base that
decision based decisions on yeah just
for a little bit more context these are
usually pretty quick they're like two
three minute hearings and I'm really
kind of my caricatured portrayal of this
is that a judge looks at deep in
someone's eyes and says are you the kind
of person that's gonna that's again a
little bit of a stretch but just to give
you a sense you well so this is yeah
this is again one of the questions what
are these discriminatory okay so because
of even though experience and should we
use this in all sorts of different
disciplines but there's recently been a
push to adopt algorithms I'll say
algorithms in quotes here because really
these are just check lists like this and
they in so here we have a bunch of
different risk factors we have points
assigned to each of these things and so
let's take our hypothetical defendant
with two prior convictions to prior
failures to appear and no prior to
failures to appear in the last two years
and no prior failures to appear before
that this is a real risk assessment tool
that is deployed across the country and
we just add up points for all these
people and now
see this person scored a five out of
seven and we might call that high-risk
now again this is in some sense the
exact opposite of deep learning this is
you know it's for good reason here that
we want something interpretable we want
something simple we want something that
in fact doesn't even require a computer
to implement and I won't talk about it
here but what we actually find is of
these very simple interpretive rules at
least in this context are competitive
with state-of-the-art methods and so
that's just okay I'm an aside but no
this isn't a crazy thing to do you know
really what are they doing they're just
running logistic regression in the back
with maybe you know 20 features they're
doing some sort of selection and they
don't seem to be terrible at that
predictive performance okay so now this
is just background so now I want to make
two formal assumptions that I'll stick
to you for most of this talk and I'm
gonna come back to this at the end so
the first big assumption is that these
are all prediction problems and so we
need some label and I'm gonna make the
assumption that that we know that true
label so in the criminal justice context
we're trying to predict whether or not
someone will recidivate if released and
I'm gonna assume that we know the why so
what does that mean that really embeds
two separate conditions the first is
that we observe exactly what that person
is doing it all times really simple it's
a narrow case so if they go an out and
committed a crime we actually know it
again kind of foreshadowing what I might
talk about later is we don't know that
in general because how do we only have
these proxies of for example whether
they were arrested so we know whether
someone's arrested but not actually
whether they committed the crime so for
now I'm assume we know exactly what that
label is whether they committed the
crime not just whether they're arrested
and the second thing that's embedded in
this assumption is that we really know
the counterfactual we know what would
have happened had they been released
historical data that we're training on
we don't know that we only know what
happened conditional on the judges
action and so all of this counterfactual
estimation I'm rolling it into this Y
which you can think of as a potential
outcome so there is definitely this is
you can't just like give me the Y's that
I can fit these things but I'm assuming
right now that we know everything
perfectly so this is a big assumption
let me come back to this
the second assumption I'm gonna argue is
not actually that big and so what does
this mean that the second assumption is
that we can compute this risk perfectly
and this doesn't mean that we're an
Oracle it doesn't mean that we know for
sure whether or not someone is going to
reoffended on't have any estimation
error so very specifically if you give
me a set of covariates acts and this is
just defined that do that you know this
might be someone's age one's criminal
history all this stuff that I can
compute this thing exactly the
probability that they would reoffended
conditional on those covariance so again
this is an assumption it's like not it's
like a moderately big assumption in the
sense that if I need a lots of data and
if I'm a frequentist I can cut up the
world and to all these little bins let's
assume everything it's discrete and now
I'm going to look in each of these bins
and see what happened with that Y that I
can estimate this in the real world I
have to do some regularization I'm
assuming linearity or some other
functional form and I'm gonna fit this
model and so there's something wrapped
in here but I would say for the most
part when we have lots of data and we
don't have this covariant dimension it's
not super high then we can do this
reasonably well so it's still a big
assumption we're still on assumption but
I would say it's not nearly as big as
this first assumption which I'm gonna
come back to so this is it's a good
question it's it's a little bit there's
like semantic slippage here so typically
you just think of the individual as
their Cove area after I mean every
individual is kind of distinct and so in
that sense what does this even mean if
I'm talking about an individual but to
the extent that we have you know
statistical analysis we're collapsing
that essence of that individual or
whatever we want to call it - aver -
available covariance but I'm gonna use
the terminology this individuals risk
even though I'm saying what that same it
really means is based on this covariant
vector X that I have access to so there
is no sense of true risk anywhere other
than this definition which is contingent
on X and that's what I'm gonna
yeah so that would doubt say how why is
this even plausible but in general I
could just write this down but it
doesn't have to be discrete it doesn't
you know I don't have to have lots of
data I'm just saying I can estimate this
thing perfectly but of course in
practice the only way I can do this
yes so again just to make sure that I
understand it means that you know the
Bayes optimal 2d exactly I'm taking the
for this kind of high-level discussion
right now I'm assumed that there's no
estimation error that I know everything
exactly and a lot of the assumptions are
going into this first ok so now what
does this mean to go from features here
my X's like Age criminal histories to a
decision at the end whether or not to
detain someone in the Sun for simplicity
I'll assume is binary well what that
means is that first I mean often again
this is a stylized pipeline but I think
it's a useful depiction is that I'll
assume that first you make the
prediction the risk estimation then you
take that risk estimation and you make
some decision based on that and your
decision is gonna be based on the risk
it's also gonna be based on the features
so the way I've drawn this is this is
redundant I mean in it doesn't really
matter if I have that box the decision
is based on the features ok that's just
like a tautology there but the reason I
wrote it this way is to highlight the
fact that the prediction should play an
important role in the ultimate decision
ok so let's look at each of these boxes
in turn first let's look at the
prediction box so the prediction by
assumption we know exactly we're just
assuming that we we have this risk
exactly conditional on the features X so
if you give me the ox and it's gonna
depend a lot on the features X but if
you give me the X then I know this risk
exactly so that's the prediction box
ok so let's think a little bit about
what the structure of that prediction is
so here as I change ax so now this is
really the key slide of the talk once we
understand this object everything
is pretty straightforward so I have my
risk I've set my covariates X and now I
can ask for every individual in the
population what is their risk yeah I'm
gonna get a distribution of risk across
my population so that origin ad here is
not from estimation error it's coming
from differences in the population so
some people might be older not have much
criminal history they might be on this
side
some people might be younger have a lot
of criminal history they might be on
this side so I have this variation
across the population but there's no
estimation here in this in this picture
so if X is super other thing X is not
informative so X basically doesn't give
me anything that I can use for this risk
estimation what is this distribution
going to look like it's going to look
like a point mass right at the mean so
it's gonna be very low variance right at
the mean and why is that because I can't
distinguish between anybody so if X is
just you know something that has nothing
to do with individuals and I said well
what is your probability reoffending
conditional on these covariance that you
gave me that happen to not be
informative well all I can do is guess
the base rate so it's just gonna be
point Mouse right at the me now if X is
super informative what is this gonna
look like will be concentrated at zero
in one so it'll have high variance it's
gonna look like this okay so non
informative X tight around the mean
informative X high variance bimodal
around zero I'll just pause for a minute
and make sure we're all on the same
what's maybe this is kind of deceptively
simple this kind of picture but once we
understand the mechanics of this it has
big implications for
great so now we have to go from our
prediction to our decision just a binary
and how do we do this well one common
way not the only way but one common way
to do this to make this cut type of
binary decision is simply to threshold
our risk so it doesn't matter what those
features are at that point we're just
saying you gave me the risk the decision
is not gonna depend on the features
anymore it's just gonna depend on the
risk and what am I gonna do I'm just
gonna draw this line somewhere on my
wrist distribution say everyone to the
right of this line is detained everyone
to the left of this line is released
this isn't the only way to make a
decision but it's both the common one I
would say it's not at least not a crazy
way to make these I wanna stay away from
from so I think it's a part of this so
I'm gonna talk about the false positives
false negatives in a little bit I would
say right is difficult here because what
do we Altima tacair about we care about
equilibrium effects I mean let's think
about criminal justice system maybe we
want to say 50 years from now we want to
have a more equitable Society in some
broad sense it's not clear in some local
sense what is this optimal I mean to be
very precise what is this optimizing for
it's optimizing for the immediate costs
and benefits if I define the costs as
strictly the cost of incarceration what
I'm assuming this is equal across
individuals and the benefits is that
like to immediate effect of someone
being assaulted as a result of an
individual being released so this is one
sense in which I can talk about
measure the Congress factor that I can
judge right or wrong relative to that
they're not pretty objection no you know
you can't I mean if I if I tell you the
counterfactual for one individual I'm
not telling you anything about the
equilibrium effects of a policy so these
are these are very different problems
and I think this is exactly where the
tension comes in so I do believe this is
a quite natural place to start and in
fact this is what people do in practice
but I do want to push back in the idea
that says the only thing that won't I'm
assuming sort of assumption what I'm
assuming I have the counterfactual
that even if you fix it once for
behavior there's still this common
factual question and now I'm saying to
deal with that but that's I think what
sharding consists of the wider scope
which is once you put the policy into
affect many people change their behavior
and then both both in the setting where
you arrest people yeah like you know
everything changes to all the
correlations are broken potentially so
you mean general you have the Lucas
critique and all these other types of
things whenever you intervene on the
system the entire behavior the system is
going to change you know so I think
these are very real this isn't just a
hypothetical but I think it's the main
point I want to make here is this is not
a crazy policy some what are you it's
like one of the only reasonable policies
and now I want to show that even this
very reasonable policy can lead to all
sorts of fineness for classical
definition so it's okay just a little
bit more intuition about what this
threshold means if I pick a threshold
let's say my threshold is 50% it have to
be fun but I'm just gonna choose it 50%
what is this saying that means on the
margin I would be ambivalent between
releasing two people and they're
detaining those two people or releasing
them and having one extra crime and
think of this as a real crime like an
assault happen that's roughly what I'm
saying that I'm happy to release these
are ambivalent between detaining and
releasing these two people right at that
margin of fifty percent and if I have
lots of if I really care that that there
is that there's no assault I don't care
about incarceration at all I might move
the threshold over here and if I really
don't
I really don't think that people should
be incarcerated then I might move the
threshold over here so this is a
external policy decision being it's
saying this clearly but your features
might actually tell you something about
some of the features might tell me about
the cost yeah so someone I think you
could do that for simplicity I'm just
making it binary but you could fold this
all in and you could say well really in
practice you actually typically care
about two things you care about flight
risk and violent crime not even saying
exactly what the violent crime means but
I have these two things so might I might
have to wait these things ahead of time
and now all of this is not binary it's
like some continuous outcome and so I
could do some version of that there but
for simplicity I'm keeping everything at
the at the binary level okay so now
what's an alternative thing that I could
do instead of just forming this single
threshold and so I can have two
different thresholds where these depend
on the group so this picture they're
multiple groups think of race groups or
gender any of these other types of
groups I have I'm not showing you those
groups in this population this is over
the entire population but I could
disaggregate that population now we have
the blue group in the red group and I
might set different thresholds for these
different groups again why might I do
that and maybe there's some equilibrium
argument for doing that I think that's
that's the possibility but it also
suffers from this this problem that now
there is what economists would say
distaste based discrimination in the
scalp what does that mean that means
that I'm detaining per crime that I've
prevented or by entertaining people I'm
actually detaining more people that I
would need to and why is that because
I'm just saying relatively low risk
people in the blue group compared to the
red group so if I were to move to a
single threshold then I could detain
fewer people for that same level of
public saving again maybe you want to
add multiple thresholds because you have
some other objective function that is
not about immediate cost and benefits
that is saying something about
equilibrium effects but in the
absence of that I would say the single
threshold is quite reasonable by this
argument you might mean there might be
an exploration argument there for for
having different thresholds I think it's
definitely possible now what I'm gonna
argue here is even if everything is
perfect
all these kind of common definitions of
fairness exhibit bizarre properties and
I don't think that in the implicit
argument is that when things are
imperfect as of course they always are
these definitions don't magically solve
our problem okay so now that was just a
bit of background so now I'm going to
quickly review these these definitions
so fairness and try to point out what I
view is fairly serious statistical
issues with that so the three
definitions that I'll talk about are
calibration classification parity which
is wide and very popular set of
definitions and anti classification so
I'll talk about all of these all these
in turn and I want to make three claims
I'll say that calibration does not
preclude taste based discrimination so
this type of sort of inefficiency that I
thought I talked about before
obviously calibration does not preclude
that classification parity almost always
will need to taste space discrimination
so this is one of the most popular
definitions of equalizing false positive
rates for example maybe you we've heard
of this then then this will almost
always lead to these perverse effects in
at the classification can lead to taste
basic scrimmage I'll define all of these
and then discuss these
okay so what is calibration mean
calibration this very simple idea that
says conditional on risk score so think
of this is your estimated probability
conditional on risk score the actual
likelihood of recidivism is the same
across groups hey so this is gonna be
this is gonna hold trivially if I don't
have any estimation error and my
protected group is is one of my Cobra
attacks because in the extreme models
and you're gonna work out but in general
it doesn't have to hold but this is an
example of something that is so this is
a very good point and so there's some
slippage this is the way it's typically
defined in that we're talking about the
fairness of decisions ultimately and I
think that is what matters but the way
that people often audit these algorithms
is by looking at whether these risk
scores are calibrated in this sense so
the Ritz of the the algorithm was
designed to estimate someone's risk we
can ask does it do that job accurately
once you have that risk you can do
whatever you want and maybe you're gonna
draw a threshold and you can ask it to a
more social level whether or not you
should detain everyone who has an
estimated risk of 75% but the definition
again this is in my definition it's just
the one I'm going to put out there
that's common is to see if it if the
score though I actually made a stronger
assumption but now I'm switching and I'm
saying let's so I made the assumption
that you know the true risk score is
given ax so now I am switching and
saying let's look at the empirical
definitions and see how they play out
okay so let's look at the empirical
definition and so this is real data now
and we can ask is this score calibrated
I'm going to show in a minute why
calibration doesn't imply that
assumption I want which is why my
assumption is stronger okay so here we
have we have that that people who score
or this is black and white defendants
who score seven for example have about a
60% chance a recidivating okay so now
let's see how we can have a
discriminatory eminent use this loosely
but I would say many of us would agree
this would be a discriminatory rule even
if we have calibrated scores so this is
a good point so how does how does one
actually estimate the y-axis this is
tricky because we don't so I am claiming
this is your real likelihood of
recidivism really what's going on here
is that in this data set people were
tracked for two years after they were
released and then we could see whether
or not they actually recidivate it but
if we believe that incarceration is
criminal is is criminogenic then
obviously that's not quite the right
counterfactual so we can't truly
estimate this oh we have to we have to
do something sneaky to get this y-axis
and I'm gonna sweep that under the rug
actually we go into this in more detail
in the paper so so now I want to give it
a very simple example of a rule that is
discriminatory at least informally but
is calibrated so what we do so here's my
blue group let's say these are my true
probabilities of recidivism so this is
probably y equals 1 given x equals
little X and now I want to favor this
group and I know the decision-maker is
going to draw the threshold right here
so what am I gonna do I'm just going to
take my high risk people my low risk
people and I'm gonna pull them together
and I'm gonna call them medium risk and
what's gonna happen well all of these
medium risk people are going to be to
the left my threshold phenomena will be
detained ok so here the point-wise this
is still calibrated so when I say that
some
is medium-risk in fact they are
medium-risk when I say they're 40%
likely to riaf and in fact as a group
they're 40% likely to Rhea fend it
unbeknownst to the decision-maker at the
end of the day there were high risk
people in low risk people there that I
didn't tell you about switching context
before we said two people in the same
group if they had the same feature of it
so you said here yeah so you're right
and maybe this is just like a confusion
of the presentation that it's a
beginning I'm saying let's put this
forward as a positive way of making
algorithmic decisions and now I'm saying
let's look at these definitions and
you're right that that second definition
here is violated
the second assumption it's violated
which is precisely the point of this
example so if we only were to look at
calibration what went wrong here that
second assumption is violated because
now I have these better predictions I
the the kind of malicious algorithm
designer has these these better scores
over here that I'm not telling you the
decision-maker
and one consequence is that I can
discriminate I can favor this blue group
while still satisfying calibration so
what is the upshot here that we have to
use all of our available features and
this again is the content of that second
assumption that we have to use all of
our available features when we produce
these risk scores and on not doing that
can still result in a calibrated rule
and so it looks fair under this
definition from the outside even though
we have strategically discriminated
against
now this feels like this feels like it
it's a contrived example which obviously
it is but I say it's not actually that
far from what has happened historically
and here I'll draw the analogy to rap I
think it's not a perfect analogy but I
would say it's a it's reasonably close
so here what is redlining redlining is
this practice of denying loans to black
and Hispanic borrowers basically because
of their race but you can't be quite so
explicit and so what do you do you just
deny credit to certain neighborhoods and
what is the idea here well the bank is
strategically removing information and
saying credit decisions are only based
on neighborhood and so this looks
calibrated and they can say well we're
lending to everybody who appears to have
risk of no more than 10 percent and
default risk and no more than 10 percent
but what they're not telling us is that
they could have relatively easily
distinguished between people in that
group that were really credit worthy and
people who are not really credit work
and so it's the same thing of
selectively removing information can
lead to this type of discrimination
while still appearing fair in the sense
of calibration so calibration in and of
itself is not I would say super useful
way of thinking about the fairness of an
algorithm and even stronger claim is
that basically everything if we have a
sufficiently rich model is going to
perform is going to produce calibrated
scores
yes I don't really I don't know what the
answer is in yet this is going to these
like tricky causal and Fritz question on
its own you know should you be lending
to individuals or to groups of
individuals here all I'm really trying
to say by using this housing example is
that the idea of strategically removing
information like someone's credit
history is not crazy and that's exactly
the spirit of this talk for example the
calibration that I'm so I want to switch
gears and talk about classification
parity this is arguably the most common
way that people audit algorithms and so
this is what ProPublica used when they
when they have this expose on this bail
algorithm and here so just to like
refresh our memories what is what is
false positive rainy so the idea for
false positive rate is first that that
we have parity of these things across
groups so this false positive rate for
black defendants and white defendants
should be the same or approximately the
same that's it yeah yeah and this is a
whole class of definitions basically
anything that can be written down from a
confusion table that's the error metric
that we can consider and then we can ask
for parity in that in that measure so
now just uh refresh your memories here
what is false positive I mean in this
context it means among people who would
not have reoffended if released this is
a tricky controversial both just assume
we have it among people who are not who
had not a reoffended if released
what proportion were deemed high risk
okay and ProPublica this is what they
found
again we redid the analysis so these
these numbers are in fact borne out by
the data that the false positive rate
for black defendants in this one
particular area of Broward County in
Florida I had about a 30% false positive
rate versus 15% for a white defendants
so among black defendants who did not
reoffended thirty percent were deemed
high risk by the algorithm versus
fifteen percent of white defendants who
did not reoffended deemed high risk so
these are pretty stark disparities and
the explicit statement and is that this
is strong evidence of bias now what I'm
an argue is that it actually doesn't
tell us what we might intuitively think
the first time okay
so again let's just work through a very
simple stylized example so we have let's
now assume that these are true risk
scores so this is probability Y given X
we just have these magically for every
individual
we have no estimation error and we have
two different groups well in any two
different groups we're gonna have
different distributions at risk that's
not saying something that's inherent
about that group it's just saying that
they're covered the distribution of
their Co very rector is different and so
I'm gonna have different distributions
of risk so think of this as white photos
and black defendants but in general I
just have two different groups and now
let's compute the let's compute the
false positive rate for the blue group
how do we do this well what's the
definition among people who did not
reoffending risk we can just count this
up this only approximate but we can
count this up and say well these are the
probabilities that they would
reoffending just take - si have the
probability that they will not
reoffended say how many of those people
are to the right of this dashed line and
working through this algebra I get about
25% okay so this just mechanically what
the false positive rate is for that
solution now for the red group I can do
the exact same exercise the threshold is
exactly the same place but the
distribution is shifted and so what's
going to happen here well now my
denominator has to be smaller because
this group is higher risk on average the
numerator doesn't have to be bigger but
in this case it is bigger but I just
have more of the mouse
Hey and so here I have a 40% false
positive rate so again applying this
single threshold rule just applying the
same standard to everyone independent of
their group membership even assuming
these risk scores are perfect and no
estimation error I find this quite large
disparity between my jerbs exactly so
this is just kind of I would argue that
this is fair in a sense and it's hard in
practice to think of what one would
actually do in this context other than
something approximately like drawing a
line in and this leads immediately to
these exactly so that was just a
hypothetical example but it's very much
maps on to what's going on in Broward
County
so here we again don't know the true
risk of anybody well we can approximate
it and what we're seeing here is a
heavier tail of risk for block
defendants relative to black defendants
which is which maps onto that stylized
example okay so this is what's called in
the economics literature the problem
with in for margin ality and so the idea
here is that this intuitive definition
of fairness concerns what happens at the
margin and this definition of false
positive rate or any of these types of
things he's summary statistics are
telling us about the entire distribution
and so they're not just telling us about
what happens at the margin we have to
integrate over the entire distribution
and now all sorts of funny stuff can
happen so just because I have
differences in the tails as I have here
doesn't tell me that I have differences
in the standard being applied and let me
sort of avoid actually let me give you
sort of a little bit more intuition for
what's going on here so this seems funny
and counterintuitive is we're used to
working with these types of error
metrics and I would say the context that
were used to working with these types of
error metrics is we have one data set in
many different models and we're trying
to find the model that minimizes error
in some particular sense so like false
positive rates but here what we're doing
is we're flipping ants on his head and
we say we have one model in multiple
data sets one data set per group
now once we do that our intuition is
breaking down in that whenever the
distribution of data in those subsets
looks different
the interpretability of error metrics is
not the same as in conventions so it's
very close to relate to what we
typically do but the subtle difference
of one model multiple data sets versus
one data set and multiple models has big
implication for interpreting it is I'm
pushing for an even stronger
interpretation and I'm saying that that
in a sense yes you can't satisfy these
things simultaneously but really what
I'm saying is that if we believe that
fairness is more closely aligned with
the idea of a threshold and these
marginal decisions which I think is
representative of the kind of classical
literature on this then this newer idea
of thinking about fairness in terms of
false positive rates really has
fundamental problems now one can push
back and say oh the problems are in the
classical definitions in really the
right definition is in terms of this
classification parody I personally find
that a harder argument to make but one
could make that argument
now they just push back a little bit
more on the intuition here so here we
have these two different groups with two
different false positive rates and we
might say okay look this group has a
high false positive rate and we want to
lower it so what can we do well one
thing we can do is we can go out and
arrest a bunch of college protesters so
this clearly is making this group worse
off but mechanically what's happening we
can see if false positive rates is all
of a sudden these extra people these
low-risk people that we're going to
immediately release we don't change
anybody else's decision we don't change
anybody else's risk we just take these
low-risk people and we put them over
here and now we're gonna have our lower
false positive rate so we went from this
which many people at least using this
false positive parity definition would
say this group is being treated
unfairly to this to be like oh now
everything is okay but really we've made
this group much worse off so again just
another illustration about these things
are sort of strange properties of
looking at something like aggregate
false positive rates as opposed to
looking at things like the marginal
decision false positive is the way I
defined it the among people who would
not have been really offended if
released how many of them are deemed
high risk and so here what's going on is
none of these people were deemed high
risk so none of these people go into the
numerator but most of these people would
not have reoffended they're all low risk
people and so they go into the
denominator so that's that's the
standard definition of false positive
okay
so again all of these definitions and
all you can think about precision skins
got recall you could have got all of
these different types of parity
constraints and they all suffer from
this issue of inform our analogy so now
I think I just have a few minutes left
let me sorry I was going to talk a
little bit about a handy classification
but I'm going to skip this here the idea
is that in some situations we might
actively want to use protected
characteristics and not doing that can
lead to unfairness at least in a
colloquial sense so why is that because
that protected characteristic might give
us real information about about it an
individual's risk so I'll skip that
example and I just want to at least
touch on very quickly bias in the day
and I think I'm in it so I wouldn't
quickly touch on by some the data
because so far I've been assuming that
the Doug that we estimate everything
perfectly and I want to revisit that
assumption so here I'd say by something
is just a common refrain yeah and I want
to try it it's very hard to know we kind
of intuitively have a feeling for what
this means but I'm gonna try to make
that a little bit rigorous at least in
on one dimension of separating between
buys labels and biased predictors so
what is buys labels mean it means that
we don't that why that left-hand side or
that thing that we're trying to predict
it doesn't measure exactly what we care
about so here's an example just Saint
George's Hospital in the UK they
developed this algorithm to sort medical
applicants how do you train this well
you might train it on past decisions so
you say okay these are the people we
know all the stuff about them these are
people we admitted in the past so we're
just gonna predict that and now we can
run this going forward it's not a crazy
thing to do it's hard to think of things
other than this that you're gonna do
this application but it turns out to be
an incredibly bad idea and why is that
well past decisions on surprising or
bias against minorities and so all
you're doing is is baking in that bias
when you fit these types of algorithms
so a thing that you actually care about
whether or not someone would be a good
student is not the thing that you're
training on you're training on whether
or not they were admitted in the best so
there's this measurement error and this
is what I'm calling a bias later another
example in our setting it's like as I
alluded to in reality we measure who's
arrested or convicted we don't measure
who would have committed a crime and for
something like street crime this is
pretty this is pretty problematic
because we know that we're just going to
observe more street crime where we have
greater police deployment and so then
we're just gonna have this kind of we're
gonna pick up exactly what we're looking
for so it's it's tricky there again the
people who are using drugs might not be
the same people that are listed drug
they're not the same people as people
who were arrested for illicit drug use
and again we're measuring something
that's very different than things that
we actually care
so now this is hard I would say that I
would say biased labels is arguably one
of the biggest problems facing the fair
equitable design of algorithms is that
we have to know what that thing is that
we're trying to predict at the end of
the day what are we trying to make
decisions based on at the end of the day
if we can't formulate that coherently we
can't measure that accurately it really
raises this big question about how do we
design any of these types of regardless
of the functional form unit these are
simple models or complex models that
functional form of the model doesn't get
us out of the problem of that if that
label is not so so now just finishing up
with this these the idea of bias
predictors through the flip side of this
saying that using the same example of
kind of heavy policing in aprons we
might see something like marijuana
arrests are biased in the sense that
minority individuals who are arrested
for marijuana use might be less likely
to commit violent acts in the future
than white individuals who are arrested
for marijuana right why is that because
there might be this over policing on in
these minority neighborhoods and so that
means that that marginal information
that we get from one arrest for a black
individual is less than we're getting
for the arrest for a white individual
now if that's the case including in the
model and just look at a simple linear
forum it's gonna mean that we're
overstating the risk of minorities and
we're under estimating the risk of what
a simple fix for this if we believe our
labels is we just fit a more complex
model we fit something with interactions
or we fit separate models and then we
can automatically deal with this we
might learn that one marijuana arrest
for someone who is black or Hispanic
only increases sones risk by five
percentage point but that same arrest
increases Owens risk by ten percentage
points if so that's a very simple fix
but this kind of points this idea of why
we might need to use that sensitive
information in the model itself when
determining risk
so here I'll just read this quote from
Sandra Mason she has this paper bison
bias out that makes this point as well
in New Orleans she's talking about
herself New Orleans when I worked there
as public defender the significance of a
roster vary by race if a black man had
three arrests in his past it suggested
only that he been living in New Orleans
black men were arrested all the time for
trivial things if a white man had three
arrests on the other end I suggested he
was really bad news so again this exact
same thing that the same kind of
observed criminal history can mean very
different things
across different groups and if one
doesn't adjust for that that it can lead
our risk estimates current astray and
lead to this type of discrimination okay
so just wrapping up what is a kind of
punchline here there are many ways to
formalize equity and we talked about a
few of them the classification parody
calibration and I didn't really talk
about anti classification was the idea
that that we can't use protected
characteristics and I'm saying that many
of these definitions like all these
three definitions these Constitution's I
talked about kamek can't accommodate
this very kind of classical intuitive
understanding of equity for example
equality out the margin yeah and in my
mind this just kind of highlights this
this danger of trying to formalize
equity too much in saying well here's my
mathematical definition we're gonna look
at equalized we're gonna look at equal
parity or we look at parity of false
positive rates and now we're just going
to design systems with that constraint
to built in without really interrogating
what are the downstream consequences of
using that when designing these types
so I think that's that's one of our
points and the second is this much
higher level point and that statistical
algorithms are good at estimation and
giving us things like risk but they
don't really tell us much about what
policy to take and so in the case of
pretrial decisions instead of detaining
individuals we might for example explore
non-custodial intervention since it's
exactly what we're trying to do is that
we're active in to pulling these types
of interventions in the criminal justice
system and so for example if someone is
deemed to be a high flight risk
maybe that's because they don't have
easy access to transport and so if you
were to get them a car to get to get to
court that my traumatically lower
someone's risk and so thinking about how
do we can intervene in lower someone's
risk I think it's not something the
outcome itself is telling us but it's
very important we're designing these
tires so if you're interested please
take a look at these two papers that go
over much of when I talked about today
in more detail and if you're more
broadly interested in these types of
policy interventions that were rolling
out on this kind of intersection of
policy equity and algorithms check out
some of the work
all right so we have tiny for one-inch
questions and if the next week that
could come up it's been a part of the
talk that you
but you think if what I personally say
or exactly so I think this is this
you're right this is exactly what I kind
of skipped over in the talk is that
there is this idea that you can be bias
the algorithm by blinding it and you're
exactly right that you can't do that and
here I was trying to push even further
in saying in many cases you don't even
want to try to do that that you get real
useful information by included these
characteristics that we think of as
protected in the algorithm itself so not
just learn to get merely by the
correlations but using it explicitly so
I think so races we haven't found
empirical evidence that adding race
improves the quality of these types of
algorithms but there is a lot of
empirical evidence both from our group
and from other people that gender is
super informative and so if the same
criminal history women tend to
reoffended and so Wisconsin is one
example the state of Wisconsin is using
gender gender specific risk tools this
actually went up all the way to the
Wisconsin state Supreme Court and the
court deemed that this was an acceptable
use of gender of this protected
characteristic in the model I think it's
pretty complicated I mean the flip side
it's really questionable if why do you
not ask someone about the race because
you're afraid that who makes the
decision is a humanities bias it's a
different model and earnest decision is
being made by objective algorithm that's
trying to optimize
utility so there are two different
scenarios here
maybe so is the idea that you're trying
to D by a see other information yeah so
this is so I said it so this is related
to this question over here that that one
property a kind of popular approach is
we really want to take the orthogonal
projection we're going to like you know
get rid of race and say now will you
told me about income but if you tell me
about income that's really telling me
about race and so let's try to like get
rid of some of that information and the
argument is unfortunately I kind of
apologized I couldn't get to the
examples but the argument that I am
making at a high level is that in some
cases you explicitly want to use that
race information yeah and this is
counterintuitive many people you know
the kind of a default is a lot of how
these papers open it as well by law we
can't use these characteristics and in
fact you can if there's a good reason
and this is the example of gender that
we can use in that case leaves Wisconsin
deem that we can use it so I'm I'm gonna
get pulled off but but I'm happy to
please please for ask me outside and
please ask me questions okay there